the movie starts as a horde of people
have lined up outside a meat shop which
is supposedly selling a
never-before-tasted exotic Mead that
people are willing to pay any amount for
the meat such as its taste these turn
into weeks but the crowd is showing no
signs of slowing down rather it's
increasing even the policemen and
politicians have jumped on the bandwagon
one day a curious customer finally asks
the burning question which animal does
the meat belong to the male butcher
responds that it is pork that hails all
the way from Iran soon the word spreads
in the neighborhood like wildfire making
the meat shop even more crowded The
Butchers who were once struggling to
meet basic demands have now started
making six figures even the large Meat
factories are forced to go out of
business due to the arrival of this
Iranian meat we are then shown how this
meat shop went viral in the first place
run by passionate butchers Vincent and
Sophie who also happen to be a couple
the meat shop lies in the outskirts of
Paris sorry Perry at first glance it
looks as if the couple's life is smooth
sailing however Things Are very
different internally the shop hardly
attracts any customers and the ones that
eventually come are repulsed by
Vincent's strange massages on the meat
one day a group of masked vegan
activists attacks the shop they throw
blood at the couple and trash the place
before fleeing Furious Vincent chases
after them and manages to pin one to the
ground after a bit of a struggle he also
unmasks the activist however the vegan's
groupmates quickly arrive at the scene
and rescue him before leaving they also
beat up Vincent leaving him agitated
maybe Vincent should spend more time
pumping iron and less time touch and
meat later in the day the couple visits
their friend Stephanie and Mark's home
for lunch in the kitchen Sophie cries to
Stephanie revealing how the bank refused
to give them a loan and that they are
going bankrupt Stephanie initially tries
to cheer her friend up but soon starts
boasting about how her husband makes
good money it's then revealed that
Stephanie and her husband Mark also own
a butcher shop that's doing very well
after a while as the two couples have
dinner together Vincent brings up the
incident from earlier in which his shop
was vandalized first of all Mark makes
fun of him for not installing any
security measures but then he brings out
a rifle and gives it to Vincent he
mentions that the gun is to protect the
meat shop from vegan extremists Vincent
does not have a gun license but he
accepts the gift anyway the vegans won't
mind these bullets ain't made of cow on
their way back home Sophie tells her
husband that she's been thinking of
divorcing him as their marriage has
become boring being the wise man that he
is Vincent ignores her completely and
soon he spots one of the vegan
extremists that trashed his shop earlier
to teach the prick a lesson Vincent puts
his car in Reverse in an attempt to
knock him down however he loses control
of his car and ends up killing the man
panicked he proceeds to dial the police
and confess that it was an accident but
Sophie stops him fearing a long prison
sentence instead she suggests that they
should copy a serial killer named
Michelle Francois who dissected his
victims into left them in garbage bags
all over the city Vincent realizes that
his wife has been watching too many
serial killer shows but he nonetheless
agrees to her idea plus maybe they can
shop this dude up and make some money at
night he places the corpse in his shop
and starts butchering it in the process
an ear falls to the ground and Vincent's
dog gobbles it up in an instant after
dissecting the body for hours it gets
really late so Vincent plans to get rid
of it early in the morning the next day
he wakes up late and finds the meat
missing as he frantically looks for it
Mrs coin yard a regular customer arrives
at the shop she mentions that she loved
the meat Sophie sold her so much that
she's back to purchase more it turns out
Sophie inadvertently sold the human meat
to an unsuspecting Mrs coin yard
mistaking it for pork taken aback
Vincent tries to persuade her to buy
other pieces of meat but the lady
insists she only wants what she was
given earlier as the two go back and
forth Sophie becomes intrigued and
demands to buy the meat unable to reveal
the truth in front of the customer
Vincent reluctantly passes his wife a
piece of human flesh but to his surprise
Sophie loves it making Mrs coynard even
more impatient at last Vincent makes up
a story that he acquired the meat from
Iran and that's why it's so rare and
tasty he then reluctantly sells a good
chunk of the meat to Mrs coin yard and
as soon as she leaves he reveals
everything to his wife surprisingly
Sophie doesn't seem to mind consuming
human flesh instead she suggests selling
the meat saying it might be the best way
to get rid of the dead body as expected
Vincent is horrified by her suggestion
and gets ready to throw away the meat
however before he can do so another
customer enters the shop and demands the
meat that Mrs coynard purchased slowly
the Iranian meat becomes a sensation in
the neighborhood and the couple makes a
ton of money after selling it seeing the
popularity of the product Skyrocket
Vincent grows curious and later that
night he takes a piece of the meat home
he hesitantly tries it but to his
surprise ends up loving it soon Sophie
approaches him and reveals that vegans
have extremely pure blood and that is
why their flesh tastes so good she then
suggests that they should hunt the vegan
extremists and sell their flesh to
generate more income however Vincent
shuts her down saying it's ridiculous
and immoral before going to bed he also
tells her to stop watching serial killer
shows the next day the couple's daughter
Chloe brings home her boyfriend Lucas
for lunch the family serves him a fancy
steak but he straight away refuses it
turns out he's a vegan and out of
respect for him Chloe also refuses to
eat after the vegans leave Vincent and
Sophie realize that all their
preparations for a family meal have gone
to waste due to veganism this enrages
them and Vincent decides to go forward
with Sophie's plan to hunt vegans when a
vegan is pork in your daughter it's time
to turn that vegan into pork that night
the couple heads to a vegan restaurant
and selects the owner as their first
Target they follow him for a while and
Vincent even manages to break into his
room with a Cleaver however at the last
moment he gets cold feet and backs out
with the first attempt being a total
failure the demanding Sophie feels that
they need more practice hence the next
day the couple comes back with an
elaborate plan they pretend to be vegans
and protest outside a supermarket to
search for a potential vegan Target
eventually a skinny guy walks up to them
praising for their efforts Sophie
convinces him to meet up later in a
parking lot so that they can discuss
vegan stuff as per the plan the couple
heads to the spot early and rehearses
different ways of killing their target
soon the vegan arrives in a van but to
the couple's dismay he has brought some
of his friends as well because of this
Sophie and Vincent are forced to abort
their plan after a while the vegans
reveal that they are going to rate a
meat shop so they ask the couple to tag
along afraid of being exposed Sophie and
Vincent reluctantly oblige along the way
they lie about their current identities
and mention that they are florists after
reaching their destination the butcher
couple realizes that the meat shop
belongs to their own friends Mark and
Stephanie Sophie starts doubting the
idea but Vincent who is clearly envious
of his rich friends enters the shop and
starts trashing it with the vegans in
the next scene the couple goes to a
restaurant to have dinner there they
discuss ways to hunt down victims
without arousing suspicion however they
disagree over something and soon get
into an ugly fight causing Vincent to
angrily storm off as Sophie sits there
alone a waiter takes a advantage of the
opportunity and hits on her Sophie
realizes that they have similar
interests and after a while the waiter
takes her out on a ride when they arrive
outside Sophie's home things get
romantic and the two start making out
however when Sophie finds out that he is
a vegan she purposely bites his tongue
causing it to bleed she then invites him
inside to treat his wound to which the
waiter obliges while the guy is inside
the bathroom Sophie walks up to Vincent
and briefs him on the situation as
expected the latter gets nervous and
refuses to do it but the cunning lady
starts blackmailing him saying that she
will sleep with the waiter if he refuses
to kill upon hearing this Vincent loses
his temper and begins to sharpen his
knife but at the last moment he again
chickens out and urges his wife to let
the man go however Sophie has some other
plants she purposely gets the man naked
and proceeds to have intercourse with
him this finally Riles up Vincent so he
beats the poor man to death I get that
this movie's a metaphor or whatever but
geez the next day Sophie gets a call
from her friend Stephanie who tells her
about last night's vandalism the butcher
couple immediately reached the scene
pretending to be concerned there they
see Mark arguing with a police officer
it turns out he is the same officer who
is investigating the vandalism of
Vincent's butcher shop afterwards the
officer asks to speak to Vincent
privately Vincent initially panics but
soon it's revealed that the police
officer is also heard about the famous
Iranian pork and he wants to buy some
eager to earn more money Vincent
promptly says yes and later that day the
couple again sells human meat numerous
customers line up for the product and as
a result it gets sold out within an hour
hence they decide to make vegan hunting
a regular thing and with the help of
some deadly weapons and sophisticated
techniques they begin a daily Killing
Spree by the end of the week they
increase the price of the meat and
generate a high profit one day while on
lunch with their friends the couple
bring along the fake Iranian pork and
like the previous customers Stephanie
and Mark also immediately fall in love
with the taste but suddenly while
chewing on the Mead Mark bites onto
something metallic Stephanie who is a
former nurse instantly recognizes is the
object as a pacemaker it turns out that
one of Vincent's victims had a pacemaker
installed in their heart he somehow
manages to defuse the situation but the
competition between both the couple's
Meat Shops initiates an argument which
quickly turns into a physical fight the
husbands begin tussling on the ground
and all of a sudden Vincent bites off
Mark's ear and starts chewing on it he
then spits the ear out gives Mark a
menacing look and leaves with Sophie
much to everyone's horror Sophie and
Vincent continue killing humans and rake
in huge profits on top of that their
dying marriage is also now saved one day
the couple attends a vegan Festival
where Vincent notices a little chubby
boy the cannibal can't resist the urge
to think of ways to butcher the boy for
his meat soon it Dawns on Vincent that
he is turned into a psychopath disgusted
with himself he decides to leave however
Vincent and Sophie run into their
daughter Chloe and her vegan boyfriend
Lucas who is surprised to see them at a
vegan Gathering as they chat Lucas
mentions that several vegans are
disappearing as of late he is sure that
it is the work of butchers when Vincent
tries to refute the Assumption Lucas
gets upset he loses his temper and yells
at the butcher couple compelling them to
leave the festival unfortunately one of
the vegans who previously accompanied
the couple to Mark's Meat Shop overhears
the fight and gets stunned to find out
that they are actually butchers outside
the festival Sophie sets her eyes on a
chubby woman and asks her husband to
kill her sadly because of the earlier
fight Vincent has regained his Vigor to
kill people after finishing the job they
head home later that night as Vincent is
butchering the woman someone knocks on
the door unfortunately it's the police
officer Vincent warley opens the door
and the two start chatting the officer
reveals that 10 vegans have gone missing
and The Butchers have become the prime
suspect suddenly The Cheeky dog appears
and Walks Behind the officer with a
human hand in his mouth Vincent panics
but he quickly sends the dog away by
shouting at him this puzzles the officer
and Vincent covers it up with a fake
story of him suffering from PTSD since
the last vegan extremist attack soon the
officer leaves but Vincent gets a
feeling that he is on to them he shares
his concerns with Sophie she assures him
that they cannot get caught since they
have gotten rid of all the bodies and
there's no evidence against them it
turns out that Vincent has gotten rid of
all the meat of their most recent
victims either by selling them or by
scattering them around the city in
garbage bags they have taken these steps
in the wake of Greater Awareness on
social media and intensifying search for
the missing people suddenly the doorbell
rings and the couple find the Lucas at
the door he greets them and apologizes
for misbehaving with them at the vegan
Festival Lucas then explains that he's
been very stressed since his vegan
friends started disappearing the cunning
Sophie Comforts him and signals her
husband to make Lucas their next victim
however Vincent refuses and instead
escorts their soon to be son-in-law to
the door the next day without consulting
with Sophie Vincent announces to his
customers that he will no longer sell
any Iranian pork much to everyone's
dismay this results in an argument
between the couple causing Vincent to
leave the shop along with his dog
meanwhile the vegan group that destroyed
Mark's Meat Shop shows up at Vincent's
place to take revenge against them for
the betray rail Sophie tries to send
them off but without success instead
they Tire up and beat her to a pulp when
Vincent returns from his walk and sees
the Vans outside he realizes that
something is wrong wasting no time he
enters the shop with a Cleaver and sees
the vegans about to kill his wife
enraged Vincent intervenes and with the
help of his dog he murders two of them
one vegan manages to impale Vincent in
the shoulder but luckily Sophie unties
herself in the nick of time and finishes
him off the movie then ends as the
couple are arrested with 30 murders to
their name it's revealed that Mark and
Stephanie were the ones who reported
Vincent's odd behavior to the police
which eventually led to the butcher
couple getting caught due to the
severity of their crimes Sophie and
Vincent get a death sentence that's it
Jesus I was expecting a I don't know
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching